would you hear me make Alex so you can
take the mick thick Donald fake griddle
Alex I have seen you do some amazing
things with food I know we have made
some homemade versions of the Crunchwrap
supreme which is my favorite thing and a
version of the Egg McMuffin from
McDonald but we haven't made my personal
favorite the McGriddle
the sausage egg and cheese me gravies
I've actually never had one of those I
mean I love McDonald's but I just I
don't know I haven't had one don't just
see me just skipping around and just
happy that's what bringing - my has been
missing in my life so I want you to make
a homemade version of the sausage egg
and cheese McGriddle that tastes just as
good I'm gonna happen because you
haven't tasted it before but I mean like
you can do it do you feel ready are you
ready
do I sound convincing not if you're
laughing after that like I need a solid
e yeah okay yeah there we go okay so
we're gonna be judging this on three
different criteria so there's time and
effort - is cost and three is taste of
course
listen taste is the only category that
I'm like somewhat confident in the other
two
I don't know so first things first and
this is probably like the trickiest part
of the whole thing is getting those like
pockets of syrup within the pancakes
button is it a pancake it's a pancake
yeah so we're gonna start by heating up
our maple syrup so I'm just gonna do a
half we do have to watch this pretty
carefully once it starts to boil okay
some of the water will start to
evaporate out if the syrup and we'll be
left with the sugar content of the syrup
and this sounds like science well it's
one of the same I'm just gonna keep
stirring this you want to serve sure why
not if you don't want it to stay so
there's different stages that you can
bring sugar to when it's over heat so
there's like a softball so once it
starts to actually like I think if we
gonna pull the vase part off wouldn't me
pull this off like we don't know if this
is gonna work I don't know listen I
haven't done this before and we're just
gonna have to see at the end if this was
worth measured or my time although if
you're home and you do this I'm sure
it's gonna be less calories you know all
the ingredients in it were like anything
on somebody gonna drop it once it starts
to bubble it goes up really fast and
it's important to hit the right time so
I said oh it'll leave your thermometer
in there a lot of people just leave it
sitting there but if tomorrow gets too
hot and it can explode
take a yeah so that's because a lot of
that water has evaporated bad I think
we're pretty good we have to work a
little bit quickly when we pour this out
okay we're gonna pour it not super super
hot so you don't and now I'm gonna
quickly just kind of spit it out so this
is gonna get hard yeah so we can already
lifted away any hard yeah so we can just
put this to the side now and I'm gonna
do just a basic buttermilk pancake
recipe but we're making it from scratch
so it should be really good so we're
gonna start with our dry ingredients so
if you want to pour this this is two
cups of flour on it well you can go slow
but pour it into here so we sift it so
we're doing baking soda and baking
powder you're not the same know hey I
gotta get my cooking skills up so sugar
and then so we're just gonna give this a
little mix and that is our dry
ingredients we can set this aside and
move over to our wet we'll start with
our buttermilk and then two eggs and
then I'm just gonna give this so then
I'm just gonna drizzle in one water
melted butter
make sure you are not on a diet but one
of the nice things about making it
yourself is that you know exactly what's
in there so now we have like a little
well in the center of our dry
ingredients and you can just slowly pour
the wet ingredients into the middle well
the whole I would try to take the easy
route I know well you know if we hadn't
mix all those ingredients separately
then right now we'd have to really mix
to make sure everything was well
incorporated and you don't want to over
mix pancake batter you actually want
some lumps in there that's just gonna
create a fluffier pancake that's done
it's pretty much done okay so when I was
looking at these mccredle's I noticed
that they have an M on the top you're
gonna put a channel I'm gonna put but
this is a dual effort what about one can
be a J and then one could be I don't
know I have this theory that I could do
it with a squeeze bottle I'd be pissed
right now
man I want a crack up our syrup so we
have that ready for when we start
cranking out some pancakes
oh so if you want to just start whacking
this take out your aggression yah
perfect okay so we know we've cooked it
enough because our candy actually
shatters so you can keep going we need
like little tiny pieces so I'm just
using a cast iron or my pancakes but you
can use a nonstick pan too we're gonna
try to do this J I'm doing the J for you
J'son to go now yeah because I need to
get like that difference in color I'm
gonna start with the J and that'll mean
it'll like cook a little bit wait should
I have done it backwards
well you're the chef shoot and so give
that a little time to cook and then
we'll do the rest of the pancake so that
I'll have a little bit of a difference
in color
[Music]
so I'm using a ring mold because they
have a really like perfectly round
pancake bun I'm just gonna spray it to
make sure our pancake doesn't stick to
it though and then I'm gonna put the
rest of the batter on top and I don't
want to fill it up too much because it
needs to cook all the way through so now
we're just gonna filter some of our
syrup crystals in and I'm doing like the
smaller pieces because I want to give
them time to know I have my stove also
on like a lower heat just so everything
has time to cook through yeah and now
I'm just gonna top that's the thing you
buy you a need
so once we start to see air bubbles
popping at the top of the surface of the
pancake just like any other time you
cook pancakes you know it's ready it's a
lot of like patience in this kind of
recipe there we go Wow
lieutenant you did it Wow all right it's
a little crispy but and there's the j/o
it's more of like an L okay we know it
was supposed to be a J yeah I feel like
it's perfect
cuz the McGriddle is very brow is it you
mean you've never even seen a picture I
like that the picture but it looks good
though next one just do an even Oh with
my backwards J it does know really good
delicious and this time the right way J
yeah this is definitely taking a long
time by now when God my McGriddle came
back home ate it watch my soul pop for a
while I was while I was eating it
finished probably took in a nap
I probably am exid's dream in Minot I'm
no comment no rebuttal so here's the
problem because I made my pancakes so
light and fluffy the buns are a little
big
[Laughter]
that looks like a Jane she killed that
any little gentleman J's there yeah this
is a better thickness to this was better
so we'll make another one maybe gonna
crack I got it you like that part this
is my favorite part and I'll do an A if
we did this this is the hardest part the
rest is smooth sailing okay yeah there's
a huge difference okay and the a came
out great
hahaha the a goes on top she knew what
she was doing
oh good it looks like ass crispy edges
yeah it looks pretty good man this is
like out of like a lying machine yeah no
machines here just these machines but um
okay
she done and I mean you got like three
more thick griddle I'm gonna start
selling these stay tuned so now we're
moving on to the sausage component I
just decided to do a classic like
breakfast sausage patty so we have a
pound of ground pork we're gonna do a
little salt teaspoon of pepper some
brown sugar for a little sweetness to
some crushed red pepper flakes some
garlic powder we're doing some fresh
thyme and some fresh sage so we're going
a little fancy here with our sausage I
see so just work that into the sausage
make sure it's all kind of in there
evenly but yeah this is just kind of
like a classic breakfast sausage I'm
sure they don't put all of this like I
saw you chopped up that time I did I
said it myself
no machines here again except for these
boom again so now we're gonna get in
there with our hands to form the patties
okay take off my ring so we're just
gonna take a little I wash my pork
mixture and form a thin patty here we
also made a thick griddle so I feel like
it either be a little bit thicker so
that like you know I want a pancake I
know that protein in there yeah so we're
doing two I guess we'll just pick the
best one all right yeah you're going
pretty thick with that kind like a
burger hook press your thumb down into
the
and make a little bit of a hole when it
cooks this will kind of expand and
create more of like a flat patty yeah
we're gonna start to multitask now so
we're just gonna whisk up the eggs but
we should wash our hands first yeah
someone watch this for us so while those
are cooking why don't we just start on
the eggs so we can do a little bit of a
multitasking yeah so crack the egg into
the bowl I'm not the best cracker
perfect it's good job and we'll whisk
that up and so we're just gonna give
these a turn so they're cooking evenly
all right so why don't we just go ahead
and put the sausage in the fridge so we
don't waste it we can use it later
yeah we all have anything won't go to
waste here
okay so sausage is going X always ready
to go on and then we're just heading
into assembly okay so I'm just keeping
these warm so and the cheese goes on the
bottom but you know that usually it's
American cheese but we're doing real
cheddar okay which patty should we use
for this one yeah lift her up
okay sausage is on she's Guerlain oh
she's doing pretty good okay so we're
gonna eat this one later I guess we
finally made it the eggs no breakfast
hours just complete without eggs so the
thing that makes McGriddle different
though that I noticed is the egg is more
like a folded egg then like the patty of
egg that you see on an Egg McMuffin so
we're gonna do kind of like an omelet
style people tend to cook eggs on way to
how to heat you actually want to cook
eggs on a really low heat so we're gonna
start to cook this so I'm gonna lift the
edges and pour like the raw egg under it
so we are cooking all of the egg so then
we got our sheet Wow I'm getting a
little nervous now it's my go time you
make dinner I mcdead it I love a good
Nick pun over like that
so we have like our moon shape and we're
gonna flip our over like that
thank you only said this like would be
sufficient your they go back to the half
moon and just cut it in half yeah okay
and we got our egg nice flat Iran Wow
and then we're gonna flip it J on the
top wow we didn't go for a tan tan-tan
[Music]
we did it we did it I have to say it's
pretty good you obviously get more food
with ours
this is true it looks so good yeah you
got more than a few extra bites with
ours for sure I was nervous to see it I
didn't know what to expect but I know
this is tiny but you do have this nice
like folded egg so it definitely took a
long time to make this I feel like if
you're in your kitchen and you're making
this for like a bunch of people it's not
gonna be that bad cuz you're like just
whipping up a lot of stuff you know you
shouldn't just make one you should make
a few cuz that it balances out the cost
in the time for sure but I just feel
like I'll feel so much better after
eating this than this because I worked
for this yeah I'd be going to like a
sit-down restaurant of course you're
spending a little more money than you
would if you're making the McGriddle but
that's because you're buying ingredients
that you can use for a long time yes for
the most important component the taste
let's do it oh my god alright you gotta
be ready around her again goodbye to the
look you want she's so I'm so curious as
to what this looks like
hmm you could tell that ours is so fresh
the cheese looks good and also you can
see the little syrup in both of them
which I'm really happy about we're doing
a normal one first right
I don't but I'm excited I think you
really like this don't get you into it I
told you guys I love McGriddle it's true
though it's OneNote I feel like we're
gonna have a lot more flavor in mind I'm
not a child anymore I'm gonna dull right
we are graduating to
cheers Cheers definitely way more flavor
more complex sure I think the biggest
component that's different here is a
sausage way more flavor in the sausage
the sausage takes it to another level
and there's I could tell this is pancake
I just have to say hands-down tastes
this is so much better mm-hmm
this is Bob interestingly enough oh I do
feel like a lot of butter and everything
we put in there I still feel like this
is not bad for me are you sighs almost
fun though is your final price Wow I'm
so proud we were able to get all the
components like wow you can make it
yourself again when it comes to time and
effort McDonald's wins it cost wise it's
kind of a toss-up because although we
spent more money buying the ingredients
for this we can make so many more of
them now that's true but also you gotta
consider time is money time is money
money time is money I always think of
that we spent a good couple of hours
making this yeah but when it comes to
the flavor and it's high since a flavor
in the taste we want so do Lisa are you
ever gonna go to McDonald's again Alex
are you gonna call me to tell me you're
making these for me once a week
McDonald's it is
[Music]